- [Blonde Woman] My only
experience with Filipino food
is Jollibee, so I have a
very, very limited experience.
- I got nothin'.
(upbeat, jazz music)
- [Man] Dinuga-una what?
- Dinuga one?
- [Man] Dinugo on.
- Yeah. Oh, Dinu go on.
(laughing)
- [Man] No, I have no idea what this is.
But I, historically, have
loved Filipino foods,
so I'm thrilled.
- [Both Women] Ooh.
- [Man] Oh, it's black!
- [Brunette Woman] Is
this like a surprise meat?
Is it something weird?
- [Man in black jacket]
They look like Mole.
- [Man] It's Pork. I know
what pork fat looks like.
- [Man] Looks like a tar pit,
smells incredible, tastes amazing.
- My ash.
- [Man in black hat] That's
delicious. That's really good.
That's super flavorful, yeah.
- [Woman] Hhmm.
- [Man] You don't like it?
What are you reacting? how
are you reacting like that?
It is so good.
- [Man] I'm like tasting like
a million different flavors.
- [Man in black sweater]
This is definitely something
they would serve at a quinceañera.
Well they should serve it at
a quinceañera or something.
- [Man in black hat] It looks like shit,
but that's why you don't
judge a book by its cover.
- [I don't know what
this sauce is made of,
but it's very aromatic.
- [Woman] It's a little
umami, if you will.
- [Brunette] You didn't answer
if this is a surprise meat.
- [Woman] You could
say that this was dick,
I wouldn't care.
- Yeah, I know.
- It tastes so good.
- I love dick.
- [Brunette Woman] It's pig's blood?
- [Man] Oh, awesome.
- [Man in black sweater] What?
- [Man in hat] pig blood?
- [Man in black hat] Pork blood?
- [Man in blue hat] Come
on man. You can't do...
you're joking right?
- [Woman] Well, nah I don't give a fuck.
- [Brunette woman] It's good.
It's just that metamoral fork
in the road is the only thing.
- [Woman] I had a bad
experience with black pudding.
- Let me guess. You vomited it.
- No.
- It, oh I don't really know where to go
if you didn't vomit it.
- [Woman] Where did you get this?
(laughing)
- [Man] I've tasted the
blood, so give me more.
- [Man in black hat] If I knew
this was blood beforehand,
I probably wouldn't have ate it.
- [Man] Of the blood foods I've had,
this is the best one.
- [Brunette Woman] Yeah,
it's good, if you want it.
if you want some good
meat and rice, and blood.
- [Man in black hat] Just
call me a cannibal man,
this pork blood is delicious.
I'll eat this all day, I don't care.
- It was delicious, I've turned on it.
- [Woman] I want to eat this again.
I want to eat other Filipino stuff.
I want to eat all the leftovers you have.
(upbeat, Jazz music)
- [Man] I'm happy you tricked me,
'cause I enjoyed it.
You know, that sentence right there
can get you into a lot of trouble.
I'm happy you tricked
me, because I enjoyed it.
That's how like butt stuff happens dude.
- Yeah.